and this is something else I wanted to
talk to you about you know and you're
you're an admirer of Eric Norman and all
yo yeah and that's the Norman connection
is really interesting because I think
he's a bloody genius I really like the
great mother is a great book and I'm
really a great warning that book and
also the origins and history of
consciousnesses yeah that's so
interesting I read an essay that you
wrote yes it's always been staggering to
me that that book hasn't had the impact
that it should have had I mean Young
himself in the preface to that book
wrote that that was the book that he
wished that he would have written it's
very much associated with young symbols
of transformation and it was a major
influence on my book maps of meaning
which was an attempt to outline the
universal archetypes that that are
portraying the kind of religious
structures that you that you put forward
but the thing that I really see
happening and you can tell me what you
think about this in annoyance book
consciousness which is masculine
symbolically masculine for a variety of
reasons is is viewed as rising up
against the countervailing force of
tragedy from an underlying feminine
symbolically feminine unconsciousness
right and it's something that can always
be pulled back into that unconsciousness
that would be the microcosm of that
would be the Freudian eatable mother
family allele dynamic where the mother
is so over protective and
all-encompassing that she interferes
with the development of the confidence
not only of her sons but also of her
daughter's of her children in general
and it seems to me that that's the
dynamic that's being played out in our
society right now is that there's this
and it's it's related in some way that I
don't understand to this to this
insistence that all forms of masculine
Authority are nothing but two radical
power so the symbolic representation is
tyrannical father with no appreciation
for the benevolent father and benevolent
mother with no appreciation whatsoever
for the tyrannical mother right and
that's that and because I thought of
ideologies as fragmentary mythologies
that's where they get their archetypal
and psychological power right and so in
a balanced representation you have the
terrible mother and the great mother
as no aemond laid out so nicely and you
have the terrible father and the great
father so that's the fact that culture
bangles you have to death well it's also
promoting you in developing you you have
to see that as balanced and then you
have the heroic and adversarial
individual but in the postmodern world
and this seems to be something that's
increasingly seeping out into the
culture at large you have nothing but
the tyrannical father nothing but the
destructive force of masculine
consciousness and nothing but the
benevolent benevolent great mother and
it's a it's an appalling ideology and it
seems to me that it's sucking the
vitality once which is exactly what you
would expect symbolically it's sucking
the vitality of our culture you see that
with the increasing demolition of young
men and not only young men in terms of
their academic performance which like
they're falling way behind in elementary
school way behind in junior high and
bailing out of the universities like mad
and so and I well the public school
education is become completely permeated
by this kind of my anti male propaganda
I mean and to me public schools are just
a form of imprisonment you know right
now they're particularly destructive to
young men who have a lot of physical
energy you know you know I identify as
transgender gain mic myself way but I do
not I do not require the entire world to
alter itself okay to fit my particular
the self-image I do believe in the power
of hormones I believe that men exist and
women exist and they are biologically
different I think that I think there is
no cure for the cultures ills right now
except if men start standing opera in
demanding that they be respected as men
okay okay so I got a question about that
so so one of the things we did a
research project a year ago trying to
figure out if there was such a thing as
political correctness from a
psychometric perspective to find out if
there the loose aggregation of beliefs
actually clumped together statistically
and we actually found two factors which
I won't go into but then we looked at
things that predicted adherence to that
that politically correct Creed and there
were a couple that were surprising one
was being female was a predictor the
personality attributes associated with
feminine
so that would be agreeableness and
higher levels of negative emotion we're
also both independent predictors but so
were symptoms of personality disorder
which I thought was really important
because part of what I see happening is
that like I think that women whose
relationship with men have has been
seriously pathologized cannot
distinguish between male Authority and
competence and male tyrannical power
like they fail to differentiate because
all they see is the oppressive male and
then they may have had experiences that
that their experiences with men might
have been rough enough so that that
differentiation never occurred because
it has to occur and you have to have a
lot of experience with men and good men
too before that will occur but it seems
to me that we're also increasingly
dominated by a view of masculinity
that's mostly characteristic of women
who have terrible personality disorders
and who are unable to have healthy
relationships with men now but here's
the problem you know this is something
my wife is pointed out to she said well
men are gonna have to stand up for
themselves but here's the problem I know
how to stand up to a man who's who's
unfairly trespassing against me and the
reason I know that is because the
parameters for my resistance are quite
well-defined which is we talk we argue
we push and then it becomes physical
right like if we move beyond the
boundaries of civil discourse we know
what the next step is ok that's
forbidden in in discourse with women and
so I don't think that men can control
crazy women I don't they I really don't
believe it I think that they have to
throw their hands up in in in in what in
in it's not even disbelief it's that the
cultural there's no step forward that
you can take under those circumstances
because if the man is offensive enough
and crazy enough the reaction becomes
physical right away or at least the
threat is there and when men are talking
to each other in any serious manner that
underlying threat of physicality is
always there especially if it's a real
conversation and keeps the thing
civilized to some degree you know if
you're talking to a man who wouldn't
fight with you under any circumstances
whatsoever then you're talking to
someone to whom you have absolutely no
respect but I can't see
anyway for example there's a there's a
woman in in Toronto who's been
organizing this movement let's say
against me and some other people who are
going to do a free speech event and she
managed to organize quite effectively
and she's quite offensive you might say
she compared us to Nazis for example
which you know publicly using the
swastika which wasn't really something I
was all that fond of but I I'm
defenseless against that kind of female
insanity because the techniques that I
would use against a man who was
employing those tactics are forbidden to
me so I don't know like it seems to me
that it isn't men that have to stand up
and say enough of this even though that
is what they should do it seems to me
that it's saying women who have to stand
up against their crazy sisters and say
look enough of that enough man-hating
enough pathology enough bringing
disgrace on us as a as a gender but the
problem there and then I'll stop my
little tirade is that most of the women
I know who are saying are busy doing
same things right they're off they have
their career they have their family
they're quite occupied and they don't
seem to have the time or maybe even the
interest to go after their their crazy
harpy sisters and so I don't see any
regulating force for that that terrible
femininity and it seems to me to be
invading the culture and undermining the
the masculine power of the culture in a
way that's I think fatal I really do
believe that I too I too believe these
are symptomatic of the decline of
Western culture and we and it will just
go down flat I don't think people
realize that you know the masculinity
still exists okay in the world as a code
among jihadists okay and when you have
passionate masculinity okay circling the
borders like the Huns and the Vandals
during the Roman Empire that's what I
see I see this culture rotting from
within okay and disemboweling itself
literally now might have an overview of
why we're having this problem and it
comes from the fact that I'm the product
of an immigrant family all four of my
grandparents and my mother were born in
Italy so I remember from my earliest
years in this factory town in upstate
New York where the wife of my relatives
came to work in the shoe factory I can
remember still okay the the life of the
agrarian era okay which we're not which
was for most of human history the
agrarian era where there was the world
of men and the world of women and the
sexes had very little to do with each
other each had power and status in its
own realm right and they and they
laughed at each other in in essence name
the wit the women had enormous power in
fact the old women ruled not the young
beautiful woman like today but the older
you were the more you had control over
everyone including the mating and
marriage there were no doctors so that
you had the you know though the old
women were like midwives and knew all
the ins and outs of this and inherited
knowledge about pregnancy and all these
other things right I can remember this
in ignition and and the joy that women
had with each other all day long okay
cooking with each other a companions to
each other talking conversing my mother
remembered as a small child in Italy
when it was time to do the laundry they
would take the laundry up the mount up
the hill to the Fountain Hill sore go
okay and do it by hand they would sing
they would picnic and so on right and we
get a glimpse of that in the Odyssey
when Odysseus is is is thrown up naked
on the shores of Phoenicia all right and
and he hears the sound of women young
women laughing and singing and it's know
they are the princess bringing the women
to do the laundry he's exactly the same
thing so there was a each gender had its
own hierarchy its own values its own way
of talking and the sex is rarely
intersected like I can remember in my in
childhood and a holiday typical it could
be a Christmas it could be a
Thanksgiving whatever all after then
women would be cooking all day long
everyone would sit down to eat okay and
then after that ok the women were
retired on mass to the kitchen and the
men would go I would look at the through
the window and see all the men the men
would be all outside usually gather on
the car ok a time when cars didn't work
as well as they do today with the hood
up ok and the men would be standing with
their hands on their hips like that
everyone's staring at the engine and I
went yeah that's how I learned ok
men were refreshing themselves by
studying something technical and
mechanical after being with the women
okay you know for during the dinner okay
sorry
so also all of these problems of today
are the direct consequence of women's
emancipation and freedom from housework
thanks to capitalism okay which made it
possible for women to have jobs that
said at home for the very first time in
the 19th century no longer to be
dependent on husband or father or
brother right and so this great great
thing that's happened to us they're
allowing us to be totally accepting
self-supporting independent agents has
produced all this animosity I'm not
maybe between men and women because the
women women feel unhappy women today
wherever I go whether it's Italy or
Brazil or England or America or Toronto
okay the of the upper-middle class
professional women are unhappy miserable
they want and they don't know what why
they're unhappy they want to blame it on
men okay
the men must change men must become more
like women no that is the wrong way to
go okay it's when men are men okay and
understand themselves as men are secure
as men then you're going to be happier
yeah well there's nothing more dangerous
than a weak man absolutely okay all
these quislings okay
spouting feminists you hear that okay it
makes me sick but here's the point men
and women have never worked side by side
ever maybe on the farms okay when you
were like maybe one person's in the
potato field the other ones over here in
the tomato moon during tomatoes or
whatever okay you you had you had
families working working side-by-side
exhausted with each other no time to
have it in any clash of this it was a
collaborative effort on farms and so on
never in all of human history have men
and women been working side-by-side and
women are now the pressure about Silicon
Valley they're all so sexist oh there
there say they don't allow women in and
so on the men are being men in Silicon
Valley all right and there should be
engineers and the women are demanding
that you oh this is terrible you're
being sick maybe the sex is ok have
their own particular form of rhetoric
their own particular form of you know by
density okay maybe
okay we need to reexamine okay this
business about your they may be we have
to perhaps accept some degree of
tension and conflict between the sexes
okay it in a work environment I don't
mean harassment I'm sorry I'm talking
about women feeling disrespective yeah
how somehow they're with their opinions
when they express them okay are not
taking seriously or or that look even
Hillary Clinton is complaining oh when
you're moving write something online
she's attacked immediately and sorry
well everyone's attacked online what are
you talking about the world is tough the
world is competitive okay identity is
hold okay by conflict the idea that
there's we know conflict that we have to
be in this back okay of approbation yes
and you know just well that's the
devouring saga that's right it's
absolutely infant